these past few III s have been kind of
disappointing for me there's been tons
of great games but there's one series
that gets me excited like no other Mass
Effect and unfortunately year after year
Bioware has been sharing very little on
the fourth entry Mass Effect Andromeda
we know very little about Andromeda
except for the fact that it takes place
in a new galaxy with a brand new suite
of characters but even still
anticipation for this new adventure is
growing so why is that what is it about
Mass Effect that gets so many of us
excited what made millions of gamers
explore the Milky Way for hours on end
that inspired thousands of cosplayers
that created an Internet movement when
the game didn't end the way many wanted
join me on a journey through the past
ten years of Mass Effect and maybe we
can find out why before we can dive into
Mass Effect we need to take a quick look
at Bioware Montreal's history and one of
its most beloved projects Bioware was
founded in 1995 by a handful of doctors
yep dr. ray mizuka dr. Greg Zeschuk and
dr. Augustine yep along with three
others created one of the most well
known RPG studios of all time the team
cut their teeth on a handful of
successful role-playing games including
Baldur's Gate Neverwinter Nights but it
wasn't until a partnership with Luca
starts at the dawn of the new millennium
that they would finally work on their
opus the game in question was something
Lucas fans have been screaming out for
years a Star Wars game where you could
create your own character command your
own spaceship explore iconic planets and
assemble a team throughout the main
quest players were able to make
decisions both good and evil which
ultimately affected the ending the name
Star Wars Knights of the Old Republic at
this time Bioware were no stranger to
RPGs but Knights of the Old Republic
marked a lot of departures for what they
typically did for starters kotor was
projected to be much shorter than most
of the developers previous games and it
would put a lot more focus on
storytelling than anything before that
it was through this that project
director Casey Hudson was able to lay
the framework for what the team was
calling Project SFX
one September morning in 2003 Hudson sat
down with the doctors and didn't just
pitch one game but three he envisioned
an ambitious trilogy where your
character actions and choices are
carried over from one game to the next
as the story goes mizuka still remembers
burning his tongue on hot soup during
Hudson's bold pitch the ambition didn't
end there either
Hudson wanted to make a game that span
an entire galaxy with a fast-paced
combat system that would rival
third-person action games the game would
be developed by the same team that
created Knights of the Old Republic he
imagined a game where players could
freely explore planets in an online
component that sounded awfully similar
to destiny or the division the original
pitch document mentions virtual
environments where you can meet other
players and trade items with them in a
dynamic in-game economy online didn't
quite make the cut but the doctors gave
Hudson the greenlight and pre-production
began the team spent the first year
putting the building blocks in place for
this massive universe Hudson and art
director Derek Watts wanted to create a
vision of the future that was clean and
slick a universe where form was just as
important as style Hudson felt that at
the time most science fiction was dark
and gritty and that Mass Effect could
touch on a style of science fiction that
hadn't been tapped into with games
drawing inspiration from futuristic art
of the 70s and 80s and films like red
planet and Solaris codename sfx soon
became Mass Effect most of us love the
sleek environments and fast paced
gameplay but the exploration was a
little more divisive you either loved it
or hated it but let's be honest you
probably hated it I'm talking about the
Mako this was your way of exploring
dozens of well rather bland and optional
worlds Mass Effect had to offer
there was a red planet a green planet a
blue planet a white one and a couple
other colors if you were lucky you'd
come across a crate filled room but
after that you've seen all the crate
filled rooms Mass Effect had to offer
unfortunately the technology at the time
made it difficult for Bioware to create
multiple and truly unique planets but
Casey Hudson and his team did manage to
pull off the combat
it may have not been as polished as
third person shooters at the time like
epics Gears of War but it was still a
huge change compared to the shooting and
Knights of the Old Republic instead of
tactically assigning characters to fight
NPCs combat was in real time and it
actually played pretty well for the time
this is partly because early on the team
decided that they would focus on range
combat for the SFX project this would
make weapon tweaking and balancing much
easier and it was another way to
disassociate their new spacefaring IP
from Star Wars players were able to
combine firearms with biotic powers tech
skills and squat abilities in order to
take down enemies from their players
could experiment with different weapons
armor mods and bullet types to make
weapons feel like their own this feature
was actually surprisingly in-depth
unfortunately a lot of it was buried
under clunky and complicated menus the
combat also evolved quite a bit over the
course of development during one of the
early trailers Bioware showed off a
system like kotor allowed players to
swap between squad members in order to
carry out different objectives and
defined enemy weak points instead
Bioware settled for a squad command
feature that would allow you to use
squad mates abilities on the fly and
tell them where to go and what to do
despite the heavy focus on action based
combat Mass Effect was still first and
foremost an RPG throughout the game you
are constantly collecting new equipment
weapons mods and armor not just for
Sheppard but your entire team Mass
Effect also had one of the most in-depth
leveling systems of the three you could
personalize every squad mate down to the
pistol he carried and the mods that were
attached to it but Mass Effect didn't
quite revolutionize third-person combat
or the RPG genre but what it may have
revolutionized is storytelling sovereign
will succeed
my way is the only way any of us will
survive the presentation took the choose
your own adventure style story to new
heights an unobtrusive radial menu would
pop up seconds before you would respond
you'd pick a shortened response and
Shepards dialog would cut in seamlessly
the camera would even move and react to
Shepards movements depending on how he'd
respond in different situations giving
it a cinematic feel and if that was in
cinematic enough Bioware added a ton of
film grain and lens flares despite its
problems mass effect proved to be an
excellent introduction into a universe
that would lay the groundwork for one of
the most ambitious trilogies ever
created gamers and critics were quick to
point out its shortcomings but what
worked worked really well
Bioware had created a huge universe
teeming with stories to tell and the
possibilities were endless
in 2009 fans were greeted with a cryptic
teaser for Bioware's follow up the
teaser listed some of Shepards
achievements from the first game and it
ended with a line of text saying he or
she was killed in action at the time we
didn't know what to make of it
could shepard really be dead by our
double down on this marketing strategy
after the teaser by concealing Shepards
face and early demos I don't think most
fans fell for this stunt but deep down I
was a bit worried that maybe the tech
wasn't quite there to make a series
where your decisions carried across
multiple games fortunately I was dead
wrong characters that had died for some
players were entirely written out into
and decisions you made in the first game
had rippling effects on the state of the
galaxy Mass Effect 2 truly felt like an
experience that had been molded by the
player but it's hard to talk about Mass
Effect 2 without acknowledging its
change in direction exploration was
toned down the Mako is cut altogether
most of the RPG elements were stripped
clean and it was also much darker the
sequel turned out to be much more action
and story focused fans were taken aback
by these changes but as it turns out
Mass Effect 2 was a much more focused
and refined version of a series gamers
were quickly falling in love with Mass
Effect 2 was an exercise in focus and
what was left intact was polished close
to perfection the lighting and textures
were better the combat felt much tighter
the characters were somehow even more
interesting and the cutscenes weren't
nearly as restrictive as before with the
cast of 12 squad mates there was no
shortage of personality aboard the
Normandy Morden was a cold but eccentric
Silurian Allegiant was a gap that could
operate independently and grunt was a
Krogan
bred for war each character had a
fleshed-out backstories and loyalty
missions where you could strengthen your
bond with that character these missions
were optional but I'd go as far to say
that Bioware told some of their finest
stories through these side quests but
one of the most startling things about
Mass Effect 2 was how much darker it was
than its predecessor human colonies were
being abducted by the thousands new
squad mates like Jack and Thane were
cold blooded killers and Shepard had
defected to a human extremist group
called Cerberus the dominating blue hues
were placed with red and the lighting
was very similar to darken war films
such as Blade Runner and if you played
Mass Effect 2 like I did Shepard was mad
really mad willing to offer you
reinstatement as a Spectre take your
offer and cram it up your ass I didn't
need your help to stop sovereign and I
don't need it now to no surprise though
Mass Effect 2 was a hit fans and critics
fell in love with the sequel and I think
it's safe to say that Mass Effect 2 is
regarded as the fan favorite among the
three the complex narrative with
multiple story and character threads
together that all factored into a
climactic suicide mission ending and if
you really [ __ ] up it wasn't out of a
question for Shepard to die for most of
us know Shepard didn't die and that's a
good thing because Shepards story wasn't
quite over yet
on March 5th 2012 at 11 p.m. I was
standing in line at my local Gamestop I
was already short on sleep after
marathoning my perfect run through
through Mass Effect 1 & 2 and I was
freezing my ass off when the clock hit
midnight I picked up my copy of Mass
Effect 3's collector's edition and I
broke a few traffic laws to get home as
quickly as I could I ended up staying up
all night missing class the following
day all the Domino's had been set up
over the course of 6 years and they were
finally starting to fall decisions I had
completely forgotten about came full
circle like the rack Knight Queen on no
Varia and captainkira Hayes fate on
virmire people had vastly different
experiences all based on big and little
decisions they had made in 1 & 2 Mass
Effect 3 also marked the return for some
of its RPG elements it was still very
much an action game but the leveling up
system was more in depth and weapon and
character customization were taken to
further lengths it was still a little
light on exploration but with the
impending threat of the Reapers would
there really be much time for exploring
probably not so instead Bioware took
another shot at the combat and managed
to squeeze in the last puzzle piece that
was always missing melee attacks for the
first time in this series everything
just kind of melded together I take down
an enemy's shield with disruptor rounds
command Liara to suspend an enemy with
her biotics and then I'd rush in for the
kill
unfortunately it's tough to talk about
all of Mass Effect threes achievements
without mentioning the ending
to say expectations were high is an
understatement
but the endings we got weren't quite
what fans were hoping for all your
decisions over the course of three games
boiled down to three endings to make
matters worse fans criticized these
three endings for appearing largely the
same I'm sure you remember the countless
pick your favorite color and scumbag
Shepard memes that poked fun at the
ending fans were quick to point out plot
holes and a lot of your decisions ended
up feeling inconsequential this didn't
sit well with fans and they were vocal
it didn't stop with the YouTube comments
and threatening tweets either within
days a petition popped up online
demanding Bioware fix their ending
developers were even getting death
threats one poll in particular showed
that 91% of 70,000 fans were
disappointed with the ending the team
was crushed after ten years of
development fans swore off the series
altogether just because of those last
two hours but it didn't take too long
for Bioware to set things straight a few
months after release Bioware gave fans
an extended cut of the ending that
covered up some plot holes and added a
little bit more meat to the ending but
the wound was still fresh however just
talking about Mass Effect's ending
doesn't do Mass Effect 3 justice the
ending may not have taken into account
your previous choices but the entire
game did I had three different saves
prepared going into Mass Effect 3 a
paragon save or renegades save and a
saver I did whatever I wanted to and
each playthrough felt different missions
would vary characters will be absent in
some playthroughs and relationships are
dramatically different and now that the
ending wounds have mostly healed it's
easy to see how impressive the Mass
Effect trilogy is Hudson and Bioware's
high ambitions were met and after the
beloved Citadel DLC the studio took a
well-deserved break from the French
so here we are it's 2016 and there's a
new Mass Effect game deep in development
the game was announced shortly after
Mass Effect 3 but since then the studio
has been tight-lipped apart from a
trailer and some behind-the-scenes
documentaries we still don't really know
what this game will be a few things are
for certain though Mass Effect Andromeda
will take place in the you guessed it
Andromeda galaxy based on rumors and
leaks it sounds like the new protagonist
will be tasked with colonizing habitable
planets in the Andromeda galaxy it also
looks like the Mako is making a return
and that can only mean one thing
exploration based on the trailer we saw
at e3 last year there should be dozens
maybe even hundreds of planets to
explore there's even some rumors
circulating that you'll be able to
seamlessly pilot your spaceship between
planets within a dense galaxy even with
this it's still hard to nail down
exactly what Mass Effect Andromeda will
be at this point but based on everything
we've heard so far this sounds like the
Mass Effect game Bioware and fans
envisioned with the first one for me
personally I hope Bioware does away with
all the grand and epic storylines
the best part of the Mass Effect games
have always been the characters and
their relationships players were able to
forge with them I don't want to save the
galaxy again I don't even want to save
the universe I want to explore uncharted
worlds and known interesting characters
twenty years from now we're not going to
look at Mass Effect for its combat or
for its endings when we look back on
Mass Effect we're going to think about
the characters it created and the
stories it sold